>>Student: These beekeeper
hats are so annoying.
>>Teacher: Put some wood in there
now and I think we're ready to go.
Can you tell me what
you see on that frame?
>>Student: I think I
see nectar right there.
>>Student: Ooh, there's
honey, there's honey!
>>Teacher: Because of science literacy,
our students are active
learners who ask questions.
They have a sense of curiosity.
They're able to take that curiosity
and go do something with it.
>>Student: Is that larva?
>>Student: Those are definitely larva.
>>Mark: At Birmingham
Covington, we pride ourselves
on interdisciplinary learning.
>>Student: These are responsible
for fruits and vegetables.
>>Mark: Teachers wanted to collaborate
to blend expertise in content,
so we developed the science literacy
to give teachers time to collaborate
with each other and with kids,
to identify a problem and go out
and figure out how to solve it.
>>Tammy: Let's talk about
the plan for the day.
>>The students found an article that
talked about honey bees possibly going
into extinction, and they said,
"We should do something with this."
>>So Mrs. Roberts, she is going to
work with all of the research teams.
I'm going to come work with
the presentation teams.
>>Pauline: Two teachers spend the
afternoon with fifty-four students,
totally blending their curriculum.
>>Tammy: So we'll have our honey--
>>So my expertise would
be the science area
and my teaching partner,
she is in language arts.
>>Pauline: You guys are
the research team.
What's our responsibilities
as a researcher?
Yes.
>>Student: You need to like, figure
out if it's a reliable source or not.
>>Pauline: The research team
provides the knowledge and the content
for the other groups
to take action upon.
>>Each group of you has got a different
article that you're going to read.
>>Max: Our article explained North
Carolina being sprayed for mosquitoes
with the Zika virus, but it killed
off two million different honey bees.
>>Pauline: The first thing that
we wanted them to do was pull
out what they believed
to be the key facts.
>>Student: The pesticide
hasn't been used for a while,
so that's pretty important.
>>Pauline: Then to think
about who's the author,
what's the source, what
are the credentials?
>>Student: The first paragraph
isn't really that important.
>>Pauline: We want students to be
educated consumers of information.
>>Tammy: You guys want to label
it spring, fall, summer, winter.
>>On the other side of the room,
we had our action teams working.
>>We want them to learn
while they're having fun.
>>They're trying to figure out
a fun way to get people involved
and bring awareness out to the public.
Every student is on both a
research team and on an action team.
>>Max: It helps to spread
out the workload,
so that we can get more things
done, and inform the public easier.
>>Student: We really do not want
the world to look like this.
>>Tammy: We want them all to be
a part of, what could you do?
And they have so many ideas.
We have a product team working
on candle making and honey.
And our garden team is making
what we call seed balls.
They combine compost and clay
and seeds that are bee friendly.
Just by planting flowers in your
yard, you're helping the bees.
>>Max: We also have a
website that people can check
out to inform themselves
about the honey bees.
>>Tammy: The whole purpose is to
educate, so they also have a brochure.
>>Gray: We want you and Ethan
to be working on new information
that we could be put
on to our poster board.
>>Gray: We're researching and then
putting it to use in presentations
and posters, so we can
present it locally.
>>Student: Because if bees did go
extinct, you'd be a little hungry.
>>Tammy: They know that to be
credible, that they have to be
as knowledgeable as they can.
The kids said, "We have to have hives."
>>Teacher: Okay, let's go have some fun.
>>Students: Yeah.
>>Tammy: We need to actually have
our own bees so that we're helping.
>>Maggie: We are trying
to repopulate the bees
in Michigan, because they are dying.
>>Teacher: Shall we take a peek?
>>Maggie: Yeah, let's do it.
>>Teacher: Okay.
>>Student: Okay, someone grab it.
>>Maggie: We also want to
learn more about the bees.
It helps me, because I can
see it and I believe it.
>>Student: I got some brood.
>>Tammy: The nice part about
our science literacy class is
that the students get to
do anything they want.
In science, I am bound by the
state objectives I have to teach.
>>I actually see larva.
>>Science literacy, there's
no state mandated curriculum.
We didn't have to choose
a topic that was fifth
or sixth grade curriculum related.
That's more powerful, because the
students got to make those choices.
>>Student: We have some larvae and eggs.
>>Tammy: Our objective is that students
would be able to take the skills
that they've learned in our class
and apply it to any problem.
>>Pauline: Science literacy is
teaching our students to be curious
about the world around them.
With the problems they identify,
they articulate how they
want the community to help.
So even as students,
they are learning how
to become effective agents of change.
So it's bigger than just
the science content.
It's about helping to
develop the citizens
that we really hope our children become.
>>Student: Whoa, this one's heavy.
We got a lot.